Mài sắc, cân báo đầu tiên trên biển đông đang tiến sát vệnh bắt bộ.
Chưa ba tháng bởi, tâm báo mài sắc còn cách bạc lòng vĩ khoảng 2,5 km,
sức gió mạnh cấp tam chiến, dật cấp mềm một và tiếp tục dịch chuyển theo hướng tế bắt.
Dưa báo chưa bốn tháng bởi vì vào vệnh bắt bộ, gây gió mạnh cấp sấu tam, vùng gần tâm báo cấp tam, dật cấp mười.
Vên biển khoảng ninh, hay phong và hương nhiên có gió mạnh cấp sấu bẩy, vùng gần tâm báo cấp tam, dật cấp mười.
Sát vất sẽ gặp cám nhất.
Chên bãi mềm chăm của là thế, xuyên pho à các nghiệm phù bột.
Cái bắt hỏi mình, chúng ta, tử quốc, lúc đăng tâm tế này đỏ, hạch những đường đột.
Cái chủ, bại này, trí trứng tử quốc, tài tội bắt, tộc tội này, trị bởi đe chạm châu,
gây má, tử quốc tụi bột đợi tất liệt, bỏ liên, hả hồng bảo liên,
hả lần sẽ bắt chiển, tự tiếp, cân gió mạnh.
Cơ quan khi tượng cảnh báo hoàn lù báo có thể ghi mưa hai chăm ba chăm mily mẹ,
cuộc bộ trên năm chăm mily mẹ tại đông bật bộ từ điểm ngày ba đến năm tháng bay,
ra tăng quy cơ ngập lùi quét và sật lợn đất.
Anh ngường vào đất niệm không xong lắm?
Chỉ nghĩ thế nha là rất dễ xinh tầm viết chủ quả.
Đây đều có thể lo lắng nhé.
Nếu, tương báo này, người mưa hoàn điều xóo ám ở lớn ở những xinh ra tình trái,
thì tài kép rất lắm nguy hiệp.
Dung lúc và các yên tượng mở tưởng của kênh nó này và sẽ nhận ra rất nhiều.
Để ứng phó vi báo, tư chiều bá tháng bay, quảng liên, ninh binh và hương liên đã cấm biển,
các địa phương khẩn chiên kêu gọi tầu tiên vào nơi tránh chú,
ra soát khu vực có mùi cương gập lùi và sật lợn.